my speaker is Thomas Connor he's known
around here as doc he holds degrees from
Elizabethtown in North Carolina Chapel
Hill he is our most decorated professor
this professor of the year that I
announced he's won that four times
nobody else has why sometimes I think
he's like a grandpa to them sometimes
like a dad
they flocked to his classes on the great
Wars and on modern European history they
travel with him every year probably
maybe not this year probably couldn't go
this year he goes to battlefields and he
walks somebody knows the story and he
takes them to cemeteries I've been on
one of these things and you go to the
American and the British does are the
two best he might like British a little
better I don't know but they're very
good and he's a critic of these things
right and the French and the German and
he's great reverence for all of them you
walk around and you honor even the
enemies of the United States who are
dead who gave their lives and then he
can come in on the differences of tone
and shade which represent the
differences in the nation from this
experience he has written the
authoritative history of the United
States battle monuments Commission it is
a solemn and beautiful book to read
senior class officers wanted him because
they wanted this commencement the
threatened one the interrupted one to be
ours just us family here welcome Thomas
Connor
[Applause]
Thank You dr. Arnn this is really a
beautiful scene in a beautiful moment as
well I think that heavenly breeze is
going to be our salvation from the heat
and it would probably also add 10 or 15
yards to a Joe Phillip field goal
attempt
president Arne chairman Sajak chairman
brought back class president Bookman
trustees staff and faculty colleagues
parents friends and guests of the
college and most especially members of
the graduating class of 2020 from both
the undergraduate college and the
Graduate School of statesmanship this is
the thrill of a lifetime for me and a
thrill at my age can be a very dangerous
thing nevertheless I'm grateful to the
president the class officers and many
others for the invitation to speak and
I'm especially honored and humbled for
knowing that every one of the three
dozen commencement speakers who have
played this part during my service here
have surpassed me by wide margins and
either fame fortune or both for Malcolm
Forbes and Russell Kirk in the 1980s to
vice president pence and general Nellore
most recently but my good fortune has
exceeded theirs in at least one respect
none of them has known the incomparable
joy of spending their careers here in
the beautiful company of so many that I
have shared for so long Henry the eighth
was supposed to have promised each of
his wives don't worry
I'll only keep you for a while I'll only
keep you for a while
because I make you the same promise I
don't want to say another word without
doing two things one is to extend my
most heartfelt congratulations to each
one of the graduates on your outstanding
achievement and because the mood in the
wider society is so unhinged right now I
want to urge each of you in the
strongest terms never to let anyone
whether to your face or in the media
cast aspersions on the accomplishment we
celebrate today on the grounds that you
have been unfairly privileged there is
nothing inherently illegitimate there is
nothing inherently illegitimate or
abusive to others about the individual
abilities you have cultivated and
refined or the hard work you've put in
or the supportive home environment your
families have worked so hard to provide
in order to prepare you for the rigors
of higher education the second thing I
want to do is to assure you that the
only thing ending today there's a lot
beginning but the only thing ending is
your daily presence on campus you will
always remain part of and have an active
claim upon the fellowship and the
friendship of this College it's
important that you never forget that we
certainly find ourselves in the midst of
a very tough stretch for personal family
reasons and for far broader ones I would
love to turn the clock back to New
Year's Day and give 2020 a second chance
or for that matter as many chances as it
might take to produce something closer
to what our fondest hope
imagined for the past five months when
the year began yet amidst all the
disruptions disappointments and dangers
of the recent months one reality looms
large although we are in the midst of a
pandemic
although domestic peace has broken down
especially in the streets of our great
cities although forces bent on rewriting
or repudiating our history and tearing
down our livelihoods and system of
government are running rampant
although the promising economy of
February has become the depressed
economy of March and April and beyond
although some of you may have forfeited
or had to defer job opportunities amidst
the economic chaos
although weddings had to be postponed or
modified
although Hillsdale College had to
embrace Universal online instruction for
a distressingly long period of time and
although the class of 2020 has had to
make up in a single weekend for what
should have been closer to two full
months of celebratory activities and
you've done an admirable job of that I
might add the world has not really
changed I was drawn to this theme for
tonight's address by recollections from
the last great national shock that we
all lived through 9/11 2001 many
commentators on that occasion claimed
that the attacks in New York and
Washington had quote changed the world
but I remember thinking even at that
time that that wasn't true the world had
not changed when the twin towers and
those four planes came crashing down
rather what had changed was our
understanding of the world we were
forced perhaps some for the first time
to realize that our country was not
completely secure from murderous attacks
from abroad and
there was such a thing as evil in the
world we have been re reminded of those
facts continually in the current year if
it's not international terrorists but
rather tiny microbes trying to kill us
today we still confront lethal dangers
and if the evil stalking us appears to
be more homegrown in 2020 than the
imported violence of 2001 nobody ever
said that evil can't come in many guises
all of these hard realities and many
others to confirm what has been true
since the dawn of humankind the world is
fallin filled with danger fraught with
risk forever flawed it is in fact a
battleground between good and evil the
battle won't end until God's appointed
time and in accordance with his eternal
plan this world moreover is not all
there is nor in the scheme of eternity
is it our final destination the whole of
the judeo-christian tradition affirms
these things and it is not within human
capacity fundamentally to change them
those who claim to have a prescription
for making the world a perfect place by
the way are the most dangerous radicals
of yesterday today and tomorrow all
richly deserving a place on the ash heap
of history
[Applause]
well if the cosmic story can sound grim
and the world worldly reality is beset
with troubles both are far from hopeless
there is plenty of goodness truth and
beauty in the world and we know as
people of faith that God has willed all
three to triumph in the end during the
time that we are given here it is our
highest calling to bear witness to these
things and to fight for them with every
breath Martin Luther put it this way in
his powerful him a mighty fortress is
our God
and though this world with Devils filled
should threaten to undo us we shall not
fear for God has willed his truth to
triumph through us if it's important for
the graduates not to succumb to
unrealistic hopes as you begin the next
chapters of your life it is equally
important for you to gird yourselves for
what you can and must contribute to the
right side of the battle that continues
to define the nature of the world and
our purpose in it in this commencement
season it is well to remember that yours
is certainly not the first class at
Hillsdale college to graduate into an
unusually turbulent and threatening
world imagine what any of the graduating
classes during the early 1860s must have
thought as they observed the realities
of the Civil War and weighed how they
should steer their lives through that
great national crisis for the bulk of
them the most immediate question was how
they could be useful in the fight to
abolish slavery
imagine what the graduating classes of
1917 and 1918 and 1941 through 1945 must
have thought as they braced themselves
for whatever part they would play in the
two great world wars where human freedom
and right and decency also hung in the
balance imagine what the graduates of a
succession of classes during the 1930s
must have thought as the worst economic
downturn in the nation's history
challenged and restricted their options
it is common knowledge around here how
Hillsdale graduates during the most
famous of our national crises rose to
the challenges of their times and it's
no accident that they did you must be no
different our hope and confidence are
that you will be no different six of you
have already chosen and qualified for
services officers in the United States
Marine Corps
many of you will pursue other kinds of
military and public service further
educational opportunities teaching
careers jobs and business and government
or full-time roles in the home as we sit
here I suspect that some of you are
unsure and perhaps anxious about what
you will be doing after this milestone
moment in your lives well take it from
someone who looks back with sheer wonder
at how the nearly 50 years since his own
college graduation actually turned out
you can't script a life it would take me
too long to recount all of the
unforeseen and unforeseeable twists and
turns in my own career all the lucky
breaks all the help I receive for
mentors colleagues and friends all the
kicks in the teeth along the way none of
us doubts that each of you will make
your own positive mark on the world God
wants you to and the Republic needs you
to the simplest advice I can give you is
always to be at your best learn what you
can from every experience good and bad
keep from doing and saying foolish or
idiotic things on social media devote
yourselves to the right things pray
without ceasing be patient and never
give up the fifteenth day of next month
will mark the 75th anniversary at the
end of World War two Japan the last of
our enemies still standing surrendered
on August 15 1945 VJ Day the end of
history's most murder
war stands as the greatest triumph of
what has been dubbed the greatest
generation of our own national story
it's important to make clear in any case
that we don't remember so fondly and
proudly the men and women of the World
War 2 era as the greatest generation
because they rid the world of evil
because they didn't and they couldn't we
give them special honor because they did
destroy the evils that most directly and
urgently threatened their their most
valuable principles and the nation that
they loved they did what their country
required of them without complaining and
without flinching
they won the battles that were before
them with God's help just as President
Roosevelt valved they would do once they
had vindicated the national cause and
helped to restore tens of millions of
people all over the world to a life of
freedom and self-government they played
the role of citizen with the same
selfless dedication and humility as they
had played the role of soldier this is
why we celebrate them and our made
poorer as they pass into eternity god
forbid that we should ever forget them
you need to be like them I submit to you
that our country thirsts for a new
greatest generation right now
[Applause]
history has shown before the threats we
face from abroad and from within and
from a virus that knows no borders
today's equivalent of the Manhattan
Project maybe operation warp speed the
race to come up with a vaccine for the
pandemic familiar suspects continue to
threaten us from abroad as they always
have and always will the 21st century
vandals and Huns imperiling us from
within actually speak English in many
cases college-educated English sometimes
Ivy League English but the stakes could
hardly be higher if they screamed at us
in a foreign tongue the measure of
greatness of any generation of our
countrymen has always been how well they
stood up to the threats against their
freedom and the security of their way of
life what's distinctive about today's
dangers the ones you will have to take
the lead in overcoming is how insidious
they are recent polls and recent actions
are extremely troubling within your
generation a recent poll claimed 18 to
35 year olds that is only a minority 35
to 40 percent assigned importance to
such vital elements as religion or
patriotism within the 55 and older age
group two-thirds claimed that religion
was important and 80% claimed that
patriotism was important in the midst of
the urban disturbances since the end of
May mostly useful youthful crowds have
burned and desecrated churches and the
flag
to face some of our most revered
national monuments and chanted that
America has never been great Mount
Rushmore the national anthem and the
very idea of Independence Day have been
disparaged in the media a democratic
congresswoman insists that the entire
economic and political system of the
United States needs to be torn down in
order to allow for true fairness and
equality
what is so alarming about this situation
is the compelling ignorance absence of
sound discernment and lack of historical
perspective on the part of those who
claim to show the nation the path to
positive change all manifesting
themselves against the backdrop of such
a precipitous decline in religious
belief and love of country as the rising
generation of active citizens and
leaders your ability to resist this
onslaught of darkness and to preserve
the Republic that is our common heritage
is going to be tested the quality of
your response will depend in large part
on what you know the value you attach to
what you know and the strength of your
own character permit me as one who is
quite aware of what you know to
highlight some of the most important
elements of this storehouse of truth
that must guide and sustain you through
what will surely be critically
challenging times ahead you know that
every human life whatever the race or
ethnicity age or gender born or unborn
is precious and deserves to be defended
none should ever be privileged or
advocated over others we are all made
equally in the image of God and that's
that if all lives matter you know that
livelihoods matter as well you know that
each of us bears a duty to ourselves to
family and to society to be as
enterprising as possible with our
god-given abilities and with the skills
and talents we have developed with the
help of others you know that human
beings are by nature social creatures
and meant to live in community
as the ancients and common sense alike
tell us the family is the foundation of
society and the body politic thus you
know that as families break down so will
society and politics you know
[Applause]
you know that order is the first need of
all these are Russell Kirk's words
authority whether public or parental
that cannot or will not keep order
within our various levels of community
is not worthy of the name you also know
that the foundation of politics in a
republic is self-government and that
self-government begins with self and
that when individuals have Mitchell II
yield to irrational disorderly or
destructive impulses community is
impossible you know that just as it is
in the nature of human beings to sin
nations will do likewise but you also
know that the history of our country has
been an ongoing quest in keeping with
our founding ideals to correct and atone
for our national sins and make the
imperfections of our Union something
closer to perfect on this day when a
genuine hero of the civil rights
movement John Lewis of Georgia has died
it behooves us all to rededicate
ourselves to the continuing effort to
achieve true racial harmony
you know in all humility that the more
you know doesn't necessarily make you
wiser or even smarter certainly the
endless flood of data careening down the
information Highway seems more to have
multiplied stupidity than reduced it you
know the need for good faith discourse
in the ongoing competition of ideas
rioting cancellation and the dictation
of angry mobs will never be suitable
substitutes for the honest and reasoned
debate that is supposed to be the glory
of democratic self-government you know
further that more and more distant and
remote ways of communicating with one
another and transacting our affairs is
not a prescription for a healthier
stronger society most importantly you
know that each one of us is beloved of
the God who created us and that this God
desires each one of us to pursue
fellowship with him to serve him as our
first love and allegiance to trust him
as our ever-present help in need and to
acknowledge him as the unshakable
foundation of our being as we
contemplate the parts we each will play
in trying to set right as much as we can
in this world more words from Luther's
already cited him remind us that we can
accomplish no truly good thing without
God's help and these words also offer
sure hope for how the great drama we are
all living will end here's the first
did we in our own strength confide our
striving would be losing we're not the
right man on our side the man of God's
own choosing
thus ask who that may be
Christ Jesus it is he Lord Sabbath his
name from age to age the same and he
must win the battle if any of this per
seat proceeding litany has seemed
self-evident or so commonly understood
especially within this circle as not to
merit restating permit me to share with
you a thought recently expressed in a
source sadly that I cannot recall but
which went something like this in times
of trial it is the responsibility of
every educated person to belabor the
obvious this reminds us of the advice
coaches typically give to their teams
when the teams are struggling or when
their coming up on a particularly big
game we've got to concentrate on the
fundamentals we've got to get the
fundamentals right indeed we do
perhaps as never before so in closing I
challenge the graduates and all of us
here to bring as much as we possibly can
of humanity society decency and
dutifulness to past present and future
into our households our places of work
and all levels of our communities affirm
the fundamentals seek the good be guided
by the truth what God has revealed to us
in his word and in the time-honored
wisdom of the ages love the beautiful
these have been the foundational
elements of your
education here much of the world is at
odds with them your strengths will
rejoice in the challenge of defending
and promoting them may God bless us
everyone to the task he's given us to do
may he always guide protect and prosper
the United States and this honorable
College thank you
[Applause]